bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition de
cette fuite le journal aujourd'hui nous
revenons sur la qualité du 10 mai
également du 11-novembre tout de suite
on commence avec les titres de cette
édition meeting départemental à
mantes-la-ville hier pour claude
bartelone la tête de liste socialiste
aux régionales était sur les terres du
front national dans la seule commune des
yvelines ayant basculé sous la couleur
bleu marine
régionales toujours debout la france
pourrait réaliser près de 10% en
ile-de-france et venir déranger les
républicains et le fn lors du second
tour le point dans notre chronique
politique du mardi et enfin mercredi 87e
anniversaire de l'armistice de la grande
guerre les communes vont célébrer ce
moment
exposition discours témoignages des
descendants avec les anciens combattants
nous en parlerons en plateau avec nos
invités et pour commencer cette édition
cette information nouveau contrat entre
le syndicat des transports d'île de
france le stif et la ratp pour la
période 2016-2020 a été signé ce mardi
10 novembre ce sont ainsi plus de 11
milliards d'euros que le stif versera à
la ratp sur les cinq années de contrat
pour réaliser le service de transport à
cette occasion un déplacement a eu lieu
en gare du nord en présence de jean paul
huchon
guillaume pepy sofim biar et alain
cracovie tx la présence humaine la prise
en charge avec la représentation de tous
les corps de métiers au service du
voyageur le confort la lutte anti fraude
sont les principaux termes du contrat et
nouvelle réunion du club d'affaires
happy hour business club hier à saint
quentin en yvelines depuis deux ans et
demi des réunions thématiques des
conférences sont proposées l'objectif
est d'échanger entre adhérents une
centaine à ce jour et en marge également
de développer ses activités économiques
thématiques retenues lundi soir donc
nous sommes tous d ong gabonaises avec
en maître de cérémonie robert cadalbert
ancien président de saint quentin en
yvelines mais aussi ingénieur retraité
au cea de saclay on écoute j'ai fait 40
ans c'est vrai je connais bien le
fonctionnement des mines doc l'eau où on
a découvert
me francis perrin qui était haut
commissaire à l'énergie atomique a
découvert ses réacteurs nucléaires au
gabon qu on exploitait et à quelque
chose qui pour moi n'a pas été divulguée
avec beaucoup de publicité qui nous une
découverte très importante pour moi
c'est celle qu'on fait des chercheurs
français de l'université de poitiers
avec des universités de rennes
survient la découverte de l'organisme
pluri décidé cellulaire qui ont 2
milliards d'années le gabon est
considéré aujourd'hui selon les
découvertes scientifiques comme étant
deux
la terre donc la biodiversité alors
c'est d'avoir un plaisir en tant que
gabonais de le savoir et ce taux
d'intérêt qu'est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui la plupart de scientifiques
du monde entier et nous avons profité de
la présence de robert cadalbert pour
évoquer avec rie un tout autre sujet
l'ancien président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines suit de loin
la polémique actuelle autour des audits
de l'agglomération la nouvelle majorité
vous le savez pointe du doigt la gestion
par le passé des socialistes écoutez son
point de vue sur la question
c'est dérisoire trouvez moi une facture
d'un hélicoptère
mais ce qui est dommage c'est que ça
donne un peu de deux côtés négatifs sur
l'agglomération qui est une vraie
réussite
et quand on veut faire le bilan d'une
entreprise on regarde pas que son passif
parce que ça je connais aucune société
qui regardent que son passif va bien
faut regarder aussi l'actif et
régionales à présent dans le cadre de sa
compagne claude bartelone vient de tenir
son meeting départemental à
mantes-la-ville seule ville des yvelines
dont le maire défend les couleurs du fn
patrick jacques de dixmude et où ils
friedrich
le chef de file des socialistes a donc
choisi mantes la ville pour son meeting
départemental un choix loin d'être
anodin justifié au cours de la soirée
par un lapidaire les électeurs de gauche
qui n'iront pas voter auront l'extrême
droite lors des municipales
la multiplication des listes socialistes
avaient laissé le champ libre dans cette
commune est une victoire du front
national on voit quand la gauche est
divisée lorsque les socialistes sont
divisés ce que ça à mannar à reconnaître
ou à connaître comme résultats
électoraux
et puis lorsque l'on voit comment ici
l'extrême droite essaye d'opposer les
uns aux autres il y à encore plus de
nécessité d'y venir pour tenir un
discours du tous ensemble et un
d'histoire et public allemand aux côtés
de l'actuel président de l'assemblée
nationale les deux têtes de liste
yvelinoise sandrine grand gambe et
benoît hamon ainsi que la ministre de la
justice christiane taubira tous
entendaient démontrer que la liste des
républicains de valérie pécresse était
proche de celle du front national avec
les ralliements des derniers jours de
militants de la manif pour tous
mais au delà de l'opposition de vision
politique claude bartolone a aussi
défendu plusieurs points de son
programme lors de ce rendez vous
rebondissant sur les dernières
actualités comme le lancement d'une
campagne contre le harcèlement sexistes
dans les transports dès le lendemain de
mon élection je lancerai en contact avec
les différentes compagnies de
transporter un grand programme pour la
sécurité des femmes dans les transports
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas normal que l'on
n'est plus 80% des femmes qui se
plaignent de subir une violence plus ou
moins graves si tant est que l'on puisse
faire une échelle de richter sur les
violences dans les transports
et ce sera le point le plus importante
le ps crédité de 35% au second tour
contre 42 % à son adversaire de droite
une enquête publiée ce mardi matin par
valeurs actuelles et réalisé par
opinionway que critique claude bartolone
qui entend saisir la commission des
sondages
et comme chaque mardi dans le journal
nous parlons politique et plus
particulièrement des régionales bonsoir
wilfried bonsoir flammes et aujourd'hui
nous allons parler de la liste menée par
nicolas dupont aignan le député de
l'essonne qui est également le fondateur
de debout la france qu'ils représentent
donc dans ce scrutin en ile-de-france
alors nicolas dupont aignan candidat à
la présidentielle en 2012 c'est 1,79 %
et nicolas dupont aignan candidat à la
présidence dans la région francilienne
ce devrait être au tour de 8 % si l'on
en croit les différents sondages
insuffisant pour se maintenir au second
tour mais le gaulliste souverainiste
pense qu'il peut faire beaucoup mieux et
dépasser la barre donc des 10%
nécessaire il n'hésite d'ailleurs pas à
répéter qu obama était à un pour cent
avant de remporter la présidentielle
américaine
pourquoi partir d'un présupposé faut que
les républicains et les socialistes
seraient en tête
est-ce qu'on n'a pas le droit en france
dans les régionales de voter pour qui on
veut
donc on verra au soir du premier tour
qui est en tête moi je suis certain
qu'on peut être en tête et vous poserez
la question madame pécresse
et si nicolas dupont aignan évoque
valérie pécresse justement c'est que
cette dernière n'a pas hésité
dernièrement à l'attaqué je cite il
s'engage dans cette campagne uniquement
aujourd'hui avec l'intention de faire
perdre la droite et le centre preuve que
nicolas dupont aignan dérange un petit
peu tout de même les républicains alors
il faut dire que nicolas dupont ghana
n'a pas l'intention de se rapprocher des
républicains s'il parvenait à se
maintenir autour
lors de son dernier rassemblement
parisien dont vous allez voir les images
dans un instant il l'a dit et répété il
n'est ni du ps ni des républicains ni du
front national aucune fusion n'est
possible on se rappellera tout de même
qu'à ses débuts en politique il était
est encarté au rpr alors côté stratégie
l'a décidé en tout cas pour l'instant de
s'adresser à ceux qui ne votent pas au
des sus aux abstentionnistes
s'il ya tant d'abstentions en france
c'est parce que les gens ne supportent
plus ce tripartisme soit on continue
avec des incapables
soit on part à l'extrême moi j'offre un
autre choix
donc il ya premier tour je m'occupe du
premier tour et je demande à ceux qui
m'écoutent de bien réfléchir et surtout
d'aller voter car moi j'ai des
concurrents mais mon adversaire
principal c'est quoi c'est l'abstention
sur ces différentes listes pour les
différents départements on trouve donc
des candidats qui ne sont pas encartés
exemple avec la chef de file yvelines
céline julier c'est une versaillaise de
40 ans professeur des écoles
n'appartient à aucun parti politique
même si elle s'est déjà engagée aux
côtés de la manif pour tous par le passé
quand nicolas dupont aignan m'a proposé
de le rejoindre
j'ai trouvé ça bien intéressant et il
m'a laissé ne pas mon kart et il m'a dit
qu'il ne me demandez pas
simons qui m'allait très bien parce que
justement l'idée c'est de montrer qu'il
ya une convergence de personnes n'ont
pas des étiquettes non pas des grands
mouvements des grands partis mais ce
sont des personnes qui ensemble décident
de mener le même combat
céline julier qui a donc a commencé à
s'engager il ya un peu plus de trois ans
étaient dans les rangs de la manif pour
tous je vous le lisez écoutez depuis
trois ans maintenant je combats pour la
défense de la famille qui me paraît
essentiel pour la construction de
l'individu est donc quitte une cellule
qui dans laquelle chaque personne doit
pouvoir trouver son équilibre et qui est
mise à mal aujourd'hui et quelques mois
justement du programme de nicolas dupont
aignan retour à l'essentiel c'est ce qui
résume le mieux sa pensée les efforts
doivent être portés sur les compétences
obligatoires gestion des lycées
transports bien sûr et sur ce dernier
point il vient d'ailleurs d'avoir le
ralliement du fondateur du collectif des
usagers de la ligne là ils étaient
présents sur ce rassemblement parisien
c'est jean-louis roja il est numéro
quatre sur la liste dans les yvelines
nous n'acceptons pas grand paris express
parce qu'ils se sont dépenses pour le
sale avec des dates incertaine et nous
voulons créer le système actuel
défense sera mis aux normes donc
aujourd'hui est le seul qui adhèrent à
cet objectif et un nicolas dupont aignan
donc nous naturellement nous sommes
allés vers lui merci wilfried la suite
de la campagne c'est à suivre dans le
7-8 politique sur ty fil 78 est aussi
régulièrement dans le journal du liant
dans le journal est juste cette dernière
information c'est ce soir le meeting de
valérie pécresse pour les républicains à
noisy le roi sur le thème de la relance
économique avec la participation du
député des yvelines henri guaino
répétition générale en fait avant le
grand rassemblement qui est prévu dans
le département le 19 novembre et que
vous suivrez bien sûr sur cette antenne
en compte rendu comme pour toutes les
formations politiques
autre sujet maintenant ce matin à
versailles se tenait une cérémonie en
l'honneur des anciens élèves tombés au
champ d'honneur durant la grande guerre
une cérémonie particulière car elle
était organisée à la demande des élèves
eux-mêmes soucieux de transmettre ce
devoir de mémoire
regardez ce reportage de williams elle
bien verrou mémoire les avis de nos
ancêtres et plus particulièrement ce
jour celui des anciens élèves museum
nombreuses périodes où le premier
conflit mondial
380 nom résonne entre les murs du lycée
hoche ce matin à versailles une matinée
pour se souvenir et rendre hommage aux
anciens élèves tombés au champ d'honneur
une cérémonie qui n'avait pas eu lieu
depuis 20 ans raviver aujourd'hui grâce
aux élèves de l'établissement
mais les élèves donc du conseil de la
vie lycéenne il ya un an effectivement
ont souhaité qu'on remette en vigueur
cette cette cérémonie remémorer des
témoignages particuliers c'est ça qui
permet de les élèves c'est plus concret
ça rentre mieux dans le
dans dans la vie oui la vie est concrète
ils perçoivent mieux ce qu'a été ce nom
et et les drames qui ont été vécues par
les familles pendant une heure les
élèves ont lu des témoignages de poilus
un travail de recherche qu'ils ont dû
effectuer qui les a même mené à revenir
sur leur histoire familiale savary de
retravailler sur l'essor de mon arrière
grand père qui avait fait la guerre donc
devrait découvrir un petit peu d des
textes qu'il avait écrit et donc de
mieux se rappeler sa période
je pense que c'est grâce aux témoignages
qu'on peut vraiment se rendre compte de
ce qui s'est passé quand on apprend dans
un livre d'histoire c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué de demander c'est mon
personnel c'est vraiment très fort comme
image est vraiment énormément touché il
arrive assez bien imaginer avec tous les
récits et c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui à
quel point c'était compliqué redonner de
la valeur aux acteurs de l'histoire à
travers une cérémonie pour le
vice-amiral giraud ancien élève du lycée
hoche les poilus figure de modèle
patriotiques étaient simplement des
hommes agissant comme des héros et ses
amis et femmes étaient faits en acier on
se demande comment ils ont pu tenir
aussi longtemps il était comme vous et
moi pourtant ce brancardier cet
infirmier qui devait sortir de sa
tranchée pour aller chercher son copain
qui était blessé il savait qu'il ne
reviendrait pas parce qu'ils allaient
être touchées et y aller mais voir tous
ces élèves qui écoutent avec attention
acquis manifestions s'imprègne de cela
je crois ça donne de beaucoup de courage
pour l'avenir
tyrannie les rassemblant thème
et en plateau avec nous ce soir deux
invités pour parler du 11 novembre et de
ces commémorations pour célébrer
l'armistice de la première guerre
mondiale de noix le fort ont soir à vous
vous êtes le petit fils des devoirs
lefort combattants de la première guerre
mondiale qui a laissé un grand
témoignage à travers de ce livre dont
vous êtes venu nous parler et mamadou
koné bonsoir à vous vous êtes conseiller
scientifique du musée des forces armées
de dakar venus notamment aux
clayes-sous-bois pour parler des
tirailleurs sénégalais ils sont près de
200 milles à s'être battus sous le
drapeau français pendant la première
guerre mondiale et vous participer tous
les deux au centenaire de la première
guerre mondiale qui se déroule jusqu'au
25 novembre aux clayes-sous-bois alors
benoît le fort j'ai envie de commencer
avec vous vous êtes venu nous pourquoi
et du témoignage de votre grand-père
donc à travers ce livre vous avez résumé
donc son témoignage vous avez vous
l'avez même publié après sous cette
forme
si alors comment ça c'est un petit peu
passé ce que vous nous en dire un peu
plus oui c'est donc moi j'ai lu
l'original il ya il ya bien longtemps
maintenant quand j'étais adolescent et
ça fait longtemps que j'ai demandé à mon
père s'il voulait pas le publier il a
été un petit peu frileux puisque pour
lui c'est vraiment un mémoire de la
famille qui voyait pas trop l'intérêt et
c'est finalement à l'occasion de cette
de ce centenaire
on a fait la démarche donc lui il a
quand même fait scanner par les archives
nationales et on a été confortée par le
retour très très ému des archives
nationales qui nous ont effectivement
incité à le publier derrière on
recherchait un partenaire qui a été la
société des écrivains qui nous a
accompagnés puisqu'il a fallu retaper
tout le texte qu'il est écrit
complètement la main donc ça fait un
gros travail à la station voit bien en
tout cas voilà il ya beaucoup de choses
on se livre des photos il ya des
témoignages écrits à la main il y a des
cartes également c'est vraiment un gros
travail c'est essentiel pour votre
famille justement de faire ce devoir un
peu de mémoire
alors oui tout à fait le déborde de
mémoire qui est important surtout qu'on
avait déjà le document est quasiment
tout fait il y avait entre guillemets
plus qu'à le recopier et
et donc c'était vraiment quelque chose
d'important pour nous et pour moi
particulièrement puisque mon grand père
est mort avant ma naissance donc je n'ai
pas connu à part au travers de ceux de
ce document mamadou koné je passe un bon
moment vous êtes venu aux clés pour
parler donc aux collégiens lycéens mais
aussi aux primaires de ce point
l'histoire qui est parfois oublié donc
celui des tirailleurs sénégalais comment
réagissent les élèves qu'on revenait à
les voir pour parler justement de ce pan
d'histoire qui est méconnu par certains
élèves français bon je remarque que ils
n'ont pas beaucoup d'informations sur
cet événement qui marque le début de
notre siècle et c'est l'occasion pour
nous justement d'en parler de façon très
simple pour faire passer l'information
donc par devoir de mémoire et surtout
que ces jeunes puissent savoir ce qui
s'est réellement passé
et quel est le rôle joué par les tireurs
sénégalais puisqu'on ne trouve pas ces
informations dans les manuels d'histoire
alors toutes les occasions sont bonnes
pour visiter ce passé et parler de cette
page douloureuse d'une histoire que nous
avons en partage votre arrière grand
père était ce qu'on appelle une gueule
cassée donc il vend des éclats d'obus
dont le visage est ce que vous avez
l'ascension prendre que les gueules
questions comme les tirailleurs
sénégalais il ya encore des choses qu'on
sait pas de la première guerre mondiale
oui tout à fait monsieur par exemple ce
livre raconte une histoire très détaillé
et il a été mis à la connaissance du
public seulement il ya moins d'un an
donc ça fait partie des choses qui
émerge aujourd'hui s'entend après donc
il y raconte effectivement il s'est
retrouvé dans les dardanelles en orient
dans une tranchée ou un éclat d'obus
juste à côté de lui lui importer la
mâchoire donc été très grièvement blessé
et la tranchée s'ébouler sur lui donc
ils se retrouvèrent 21 ans enterrée
jusqu'au bout
voilà moment très sympathique dont il
raconte tout ça est évidemment toute la
guérison qui on a suivi parce qu'il a
derrière fait trois ans dans les
hôpitaux avec ce qu'on appellerait
aujourd'hui la reconstruction faciale
sauf qu'à l'époque c'était fait avec les
moyens qui ne sont pas ceux
d'aujourd'hui dont il raconte ses traits
opération une des premières greffes
osseuses donc vraiment un témoignage qui
parlent beaucoup et également de la
médecine mais vous connaissez c'est
aussi une façon enfin quand vous allez
parler aux clients de leur parler des
choses qui ne qui ne savent pas les
tirailleurs sénégalais les gueules
cassées ça pour vous ça c'est des choses
qui vont ensemble
absolument et d'ailleurs vous savez bon
on n'a pas eu le privilège de voir des
écrits du fonds de par exemple
exceptionnellement on a retrouvé des
lettres des tirailleurs ramassés par
hasard sur les bords du fleuve sénégal
et qui ont fait l'objet d'une édition
et alors là on a des témoignages directs
des petits d'ailleurs et pas n'importe
qui c'est des instituts normalien qui
vraiment envoyer des lettres à leurs
collègues restés au sénégal qui avait eu
le malheur d'être réformé intrigué mais
et voilà il ya une mine d'informations
donc et à travers ses lettres on a
peut-être remarqué les souffrances que
ces gens là ont vécu loin de leur
famille dans un climat qui ne
connaissait pas bon sans compter les
heures sombres de cette guerre dans les
tranchées vos deux bouts de témoignages
lorsqu'on sait que justement le dernier
poilu français n'est plus de ce monde
c'est lazare ponticelli qu'est lazare
ponticelli pardon qui est mort en 2008 à
110 ans le témoignage justement c'est
encore plus important - temps même si ce
n'est pas un témoignage qui est un
symptôme qui a retransmis en fait oui
tout à fait puisque maintenant les
témoignages qui peuvent ressortir sont
ceux qui sont issus de lettres ou de
livres complets donc il faut vraiment
les mettre en avant et par rapport ce
devoir de mémoire surtout quand on voit
les actualités d'aujourd'hui où il ya
encore beaucoup de guerre et c'est
probablement au travers de la mémoire
qu'on pourra mieux comprendre
il vaut mieux faire de la diplomatie
d'une mauvaise diplomatie vaudra
toujours mieux qu'une bonne guerre
absolument d'autant plus que nous notre
dernier poilu africain est parti en 1998
est bon donc connu vivant ainsi le
territoire sur le continent africain et
il est temps de nous constituer se
passer sinon ça va se perdrait donc
lorsque toutes les occasions sont bonnes
pour écrire recueillir le maximum
d'informations et surtout vulgariser
cette information parce qu'il faudrait
que la jeunesse actuelle sache c'est
difficile de parler justement par
exemple de tirailleurs sénégalais qui
ont parlé aux gens ne saisissent pas
qu'il comprenne pas vous savez je suis
enseignante de profession dont il n'y a
qu'une manière pédagogique de
transmettre l'information et le problème
c'est que ils n'en savent souvent rien
alors c'est une découverte et il
manifeste une kiri jsl donc pour savoir
et ça c'est important dès que cette
manifestation est là donc le reste
maintenant on fait passer l'information
et c'est primordial c'est important que
qu'il puisse avoir
parce que comme il l'a dit cela permet
peut-être de vivre dans un monde en paix
de tirer les leçons de cette guerre et
surtout de mieux se connaître
monsieur la foire le message que vous
avez si te faire passer à tracer aussi
pour votre famille mais c'est il ya un
message des plus globale à dire oui mais
on rejoint un petit peu la même chose je
pense deux approches la proche de avec
une un accompagnement des élèves en
direct et nous on a plutôt fait de
l'accompagnement par un livre puisque il
ya beaucoup de détails beaucoup de
schémas beaucoup de photos des noms de
lieux des noms de personnes finalement
c'est quasiment comme un reportage et il
est très facile quand on lit le livre de
se mettre à la place de l'auteur et de
vivre un petit peu cette guerre de
l'intérieur et je pense que c'est
quelque chose de très complémentaires
par rapport à ce que
il peut faire avec une présentation en
direct à des élèves en tant
qu'enseignants vous êtes d'ailleurs
auparavant rencontré ajustements avec la
méditation manifestations organisées par
les quais sous bois il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses dans cette
manifestation il ya peut-être des choses
vous même que vous ayez a pris même si
je pense que vous êtes très très calé
entre guillemets sur la première guerre
mondiale
on apprend toujours un important joueur
que effectivement il ya une un
centenaire qui est célébrée de façon
très complète dont il faut pas hésiter à
aller le voir puisqu'il s'est encore
pendant quelques jours voilà beaucoup de
choses au 13 août
c'est jusqu'au 27 novembre il ya
également sur les sapeurs pompiers c'est
aussi des choses qui sont peut-être
moins connus dans ce qu'on connaît la
gare avant la première guerre mondiale
absolument vous savez la première guerre
mondiale c'est une histoire c'est un
événement que l'on n'utilisera jamais
assez de la toujours des choses à
apprendre de la poudre des choses qu'on
va découvrir deux mois ici curieux de
lire ses livres pour ma publier du
contenu voir si votre grand père avait
des relations avec des tirs est il était
dans un régiment des tirailleurs ou bon
s'il a combattu avec donc
malheureusement je rentre bientôt
j'espère pouvoir acquérir
il n'a pas été dans un régiment de
tirailleurs par contre il était dans un
vase un régiment disciplinaire ce qui
était assez amusant parce qu'il a
toujours fait preuve d'une grande
volonté de servir son pays et dans un
jeu de hasard il s'est retrouvé dans un
régiment disciplinaire et bien en tout
cas merci nous avoir à ramener
l'original c'est vraiment très
intéressant
alors je le rappelle le centenaire de la
première guerre mondiale c'est jusqu'au
25 novembre aux clayes-sous-bois donc le
livre des loirs lefort souvenirs de
guerre c'est publié aux éditions de la
société des écrivains voile alors
n'hésitez pas à aller acheter si vous
voulez justement plus d'informations
c'est un témoignage très riche
merci beaucoup monsieur d'être venu en
plateau justement pour nous parler de
ces communes ration du rose novembre
merci et des seniors de plus en plus
connectés c'est ce que propose
l'association le web niort tous les
jours pour apprendre à utiliser au mieux
les
si informatique à la maison du quartier
de notre dame de versailles les
explications avec et sephora nomani
françois teillard et shantel & jehn font
partie des 150 adhérents à pouvoir se
rendre à l'atelier libre du web senior à
la maison de quartier notre dame un
versailles tous les jours de 10h à 12h
et de 14h à 16h j'avais un gros besoin
de créer des powerpoint
je savais les utiliser mais pas les
terres dans les maisons à louer le
seigneur ici pour les créer là c'est
pour enregistrer des photos bon endroit
enfin pour moi c'est un problème parce
que je suis encore un peu novice et mon
ordinateur un peu fou lire donc
heureusement j'avais lettre de gérard et
est ici c'est très précieux par des
animateurs qualifiés et je l'appuie le
web senior est une association fondée en
2006 qui permet d'aider les seniors à
utiliser les outils informatiques et qui
offre des cours dirigés pour se
familiariser aux différents logiciels du
traitement de texte au photomontage
s'est connecté les générations et lutter
contre la fracture numérique
ces hôtels ont envahi la vie de tous les
jours et si on ne maîtrise pas ça on est
exclu
les prochains ateliers dirigés
permettront d'apprendre à créer un site
web ou à se servir de photoshop et avant
de refermer cette édition un monde un
mot de sport la troisième édition de la
course au royal était programmé ce
dimanche entre la pièce d'eau des
suisses de versailles et fontenay le
fleury
au programme de la marche nordique une
épreuve de 10 km et des courses par
équipe
mais la compétition phare de cette année
c'était le 20 km plus de 200
participants se sont inscrits les
détails avec mickaël millero du bitume
de la boue des côtes les coureurs ont dû
se faire violence pour terminer les 20
km de cette troisième édition de la
course royal
une compétition organisée ce dimanche
matin entre la pièce d'eau des suisses à
versailles il au gymnase descartes de
fontenay-le-fleury c'est un très très
beau parcours avec une première partie
très roulante en traversant le parc du
château de versailles
une deuxième partie beaucoup plus
compliquée avec pas mal de côté endroit
boueux donc glissant
mais un bon effort accompli jusqu au
bout dans la joie et un petit peu de
douleur mais au final bien content
d'être arrivé d'avoir dépassé tout ça on
est parti vraiment du château tout le
bassin et puis après tout la plaine
vraiment des beaux paysages un parcours
très agréable en campagne
sympa cette année plus de 2 131
participants ont pris le départ des 20
km un record pour la course
une autre barrière est tombé pierre
urruty a battu le meilleur temps de
l'épreuve le coureur a bouclé son
périple en 1h06 et 26 secondes de
minutes de moins que la précédente
marque le record c'est pas la chose la
plus important portail de faire une
bonne course et d'essayer de donner le
meilleur de soi-même aujourd'hui après
c'est difficile de comparer performance
d'une addition
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
quatrième édition avec une nouvelle fois
deux objectifs améliorer le temps du
parcours mais également battre des
records d'affluence
et c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
retrouve lundi à 18 heures pour une
nouvelle édition du ca fait le journal
en direct
je vous souhaite donc une très bonne
soirée
vous